السلام عليكم
صراحه احنا سعداء في قاعده الملك عبد الله
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه في مدينه جده
نخدمكم
ما نستطيع نتمنى لكم ان شاء الله رحله
امنه والوصول الى بلادكم ان شاء الله
امنين باذن الله تعالى وان شاء الله نراكم
في حال افضل في اوقات افضل من هذه الاوقات
باذن الله تعالى نتمنى لكم ان شاء الله
رحله سعيده باذن الله تعالى شكرا لكم على
يعني اعطانا الفرصه للوقوف معكم شكرا
ان شاء الله
هوم طيور فاميلي ان يلبي هابي باذن الله
تعالى
اوكي
ثانكيو ان شاء الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات